MALE SPEAKER: Please join me
in a massive round of applause
to welcome Ben Miller.
[APPLAUSE]
Hello.
BEN MILLER: Thank you, Rob.
Thank you all so
much for coming.
I really appreciate that
spontaneous welcome.
Thank you.
MALE SPEAKER: Ben,
you've written a book.
BEN MILLER: I have.
MALE SPEAKER: It's very good.
I finished it last night.
It's about the search for
extraterrestrial life--
BEN MILLER: Yes.
MALE SPEAKER: --what
that might look like--
BEN MILLER: Yes.
MALE SPEAKER: --and how we
might go about finding it.
BEN MILLER: Exactly.
MALE SPEAKER: Why did
you write the book?
BEN MILLER: I think it was a
bit of a midlife crisis thing,
really.
I mean, I just got very
into-- my scientific training
was in physics.
I've just always loved science.
It's not something
I've done as a career,
it's always been a hobby.
It's just something I just
really get a lot of enjoyment
from and a lot of pleasure from.
And this book started
with a previous book.
I wrote a book called "It's
Not Rocket Science," which
is basically-- I felt there
weren't any books out there
which described the best
bits of science for people
without-- for bright people
without-- a scientific training
or background.
So I thought, well, would
it be possible to write
about all the bits of
science that I love
and explain it in
a way that, say,
a creative person with a
really good arts degree
could maybe pick up and
really get access to science.
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
And this is digging deep
into that particular topic
of astrobiology and [INAUDIBLE].
BEN MILLER: Yeah.
So when I was doing that
book, I came across-- partly,
I wanted to do some
stuff about DNA
and the latest
advances in biology.
And that just got me
really interested in life,
you know, the physics
of life, what is life.
I came across a brilliant
book by Erwin Schrodinger
called "What is Life,"
which talked, really, about,
how does life fit in with the
second law of thermodynamics.
One of the topics I hadn't
covered in the first book
was entropy and the second
law of thermodynamics.
So I thought, wow, is that
something that I could try
and-- is that something I
could try and do justice to.
Also, I just think
aliens is a funny topic.
There's something
naturally amusing about it,
sometimes intentionally,
sometimes unintentionally.
And at the beginning of the
book, whereas, the first book,
I was really in
my comfort zone, I
was writing about things that
I knew quite well, this book,
I didn't know any of this
stuff when I started out.
So it was also like-- for me--
it was like my dream adult
education course, really.
So I went to meet all
these amazing people,
incredible people.
And to begin with, I had a real
embarrassment about asking them
about-- one of the first
people I went to meet
was the head of the UNOOSA,
the UN Office of Outer Space
Affairs.
MALE SPEAKER: She's our
ambassador if aliens come down.
BEN MILLER: That's right.
So the idea-- and this
was sort of where,
partly, the idea
for the book came
from-- the idea is that
if aliens were to land,
the UN needs to have a response.
I mean, this is literally like
if they landed in a space ship
and came out and held
a press conference.
There would have to be
somebody-- there's somebody
whose job it is, at the UN,
to liaise with the aliens.
MALE SPEAKER: That's
not her only job.
BEN MILLER: That's
She's also got to find ghosts.
No, it's not her only job.
That office, they basically keep
track of all the satellites.
Basically, if you want
to put a satellite up,
you have to talk
to UNOOSA first.
And yeah, so I went to
meet her and I felt so--
and the story is in the
book-- I felt so embarrassed.
I was going to this very eminent
Malaysian physicist who'd
set up the Malaysian
space program
and had launched the
first Malaysian satellite
and was now the head of UNOOSA.
And I went to have this thing.
And I said, well,
so could we just
talk about this aliens thing?
And I said, is it true
that if aliens land,
then you're the
designated spokesman
on behalf of the human race?
And she said, yeah, it's
pretty cool, isn't it?
And I just had the most
brilliant chat with her
where we got on.
Quickly, you start
talking about life.
You very quickly get on to
what makes life so special.
We very quickly got onto
even spiritual subjects.
You know, what does it all mean.
What are we here for?
And why do we want
to talk to aliens?
And I began to
realize that there
was real science, that you
could go-- what you could do
is you could take all the
latest stuff that we had found
in astronomy, and you could
take all of the latest stuff
that we had found in
evolutionary biology,
and you could put
it all together,
and you could do a pretty good
job, really, of finding out
what life on Earth could tell
you about any other life that
might be out there.
And that's in every respect--
how it might get its start,
what life is in physical
terms-- you know,
is there any-- it's
a huge subject.
How would you communicate with
it if you could communicate?
Just say, for
example, we did manage
to receive some kind of signal.
How would we know
it was a signal?
Could we decode it?
If we couldn't decode
it, what information
could we get from it?
And it becomes a
really-- It's just--
MALE SPEAKER: I
think, on that topic--
BEN MILLER: --a
fabulous subject.
MALE SPEAKER: --there was a
point where you were talking
about Zipf's law and dolphins--
and we'll move on to the that--
BEN MILLER: Ah.
MALE SPEAKER: --which is weird.
BEN MILLER: Oh my god.
MALE SPEAKER: But
essentially, even
if you can't understand
what is in a signal,
you could prove that it
had intelligence behind it.
BEN MILLER: Well, yes, I imagine
that information theory will
be bread and butter to
a lot of people here,
but it was very new to me.
And the idea that you
could-- basically,
the mathematical
properties of language
are there whether or
not you can understand
what the message says or not.
So you could know
that something--
you can't know that
it is language,
that it is
communication, but you
can see whether it has the
properties of language.
And you can see how
complex a language
it could possibly
be without knowing
the content, the message.
MALE SPEAKER: If you analyze
the speech patterns of a child,
they're less complicated
than the speech
patterns of an adult.
BEN MILLER: Exactly.
So they did this
brilliant thing.
So one of the stories in
the book is about how--
and this was really news to me.
I hadn't realized that we think
of ourselves as very special.
Homo sapiens, we
think of ourselves
as being really extraordinary.
We are intelligent.
It began with the domestication
of animals and farming.
And then we built civilizations.
And then we discovered language.
And we have this story
that we tell ourselves
where we are completely
unique on the planet.
And it's really,
really interesting
to discover that all
those traits are there
in other species.
MALE SPEAKER: You talk about
farming as something ants do.
BEN MILLER: Ants, yeah.
There's a South
American ant that's
been farming, fungus farming,
for about 6 million years.
MALE SPEAKER: They treat
the fungus with antibiotics.
BEN MILLER: They treat the
fungus with antibiotics,
they farm it, they cultivate
it, they use it as food.
It's farming.
You can't argue with it.
It's definitely farming.
The crow family-- I met
this fabulous professor
at the University of Cambridge
who's done a lot of work with
crows and has shown that
crows have cognitive abilities
not just on a par with
chimpanzees, but in some cases,
better than chimpanzees.
And you start to form
this picture of-- it
starts to become very,
very interesting.
And you see our own
very lucky position
as being more of an
accident, really,
than a vital last step in a long
chain of progressive evolution.
It's really interesting.
MALE SPEAKER: And you call
out the intelligence--
so, the example of convergence,
where different elements come
about through entirely
different evolutionary paths--
BEN MILLER: That's
a great example.
MALE SPEAKER: --and
intelligence being one of those.
BEN MILLER: Exactly.
So again, new to me was this
idea of convergent evolution.
We've all heard of
divergent evolution.
Organisms speciate over
time, and we end up
with a planet that's full of
all kinds of different things.
But there's also
convergent evolution.
So things like wings have
evolved independently,
maybe half a dozen times,
in different species,
completely unrelated.
In fact, convergence is such
a problem for biologists
that many mistakes
have been made
since the 19th century,
where one creature from one
part of the planet looks so like
a creature from another part
of the planet, they
believe they're related
and only later find out that
they are on a completely
different evolutionary path.
MALE SPEAKER: I was
reading, this morning,
that carnivorous plants have
evolved nine times in five
different orders.
It's [INAUDIBLE].
BEN MILLER: And
this is everywhere.
So teeth, eyes-- our eyes are
remarkably similar, in design,
to octopus eyes, for example.
But obviously, the common
ancestor of us and the octopus
is-- you're going right back
to the Cambrian explosion
540 million years ago.
It's really striking.
And intelligence--
there is intelligence
in-- arguably, intelligence in--
dolphins, in crows, in octopus.
You could include dogs, cats.
There's all kinds of
different creatures.
Of all of those,
the most interesting
is probably octopuses
and mammals,
because again, it's
such a long way back.
But even with crows,
for a common ancestor
between crows and us,
you've got to go back
to what they call an amniote,
something that was basically
just laying eggs on land.
MALE SPEAKER: Well, let's
go right back [INAUDIBLE].
So you open the book
with extremophiles--
so, bacteria in a rock here?
How do I--
BEN MILLER: There's
been three-- what
was happening is all-- three
different areas of science
are all converging on
the same point, really.
We've had the Kepler
Space Telescope,
which has shown us that
Earth-like planets are common.
So whereas 20
years ago, we might
have believed there
were no other planets
outside the solar
system, we now know
Earth-like planets are common.
And maybe something like
one in 1,000 solar systems
is like our own, with
a big, cold Jupiter,
terrestrial planets the right
distance from a Sun-like star
to have water on their surface.
We know that these
things are common.
So that was one area.
There's another area, which was
extremophiles, which has also
been going in parallel, where
we've discovered that life
on Earth is much more resilient,
creative, resourceful than we
ever realized.
We thought that there was a
certain zone of temperatures,
acidities, pressures, radiation
levels where life could exist.
And time and time again,
we've discovered that's wrong.
You always find some bacterium
somewhere, very, very happy
to live in those conditions.
And then finally, there's
been the advances-- again,
this is all new to me,
and it's really, really
great stuff-- advances
in evolutionary biology.
So we've now got some
really good theories that
make an awful lot of
sense, not the Darwin warm
pond that you may heard
of, but this idea that life
began in alkaline
hydrothermal vents.
Because you get a particularly
unique situation there where
you've got lots of
transition metals.
One thing we do know is
that life, as we know it,
adores transition metals.
It kind of uses transition
metals as little batteries
to borrow electrons from
and pay electrons back
when it suits it.
You have this great-- it's
an electrochemical cell,
basically, because the first
sea waters were acidic.
And if you have an
alkaline hydrothermal vent,
you essentially get,
across the membrane,
the semi-permeable membrane of
the bubbles inside the vent,
these gel-like iron
sulfide bubbles,
you get this charge separation.
And that can be used to
drive-- as an energy source,
to drive-- the formation
of long-chain molecules.
So suddenly, so many
missing steps of the jigsaw
are almost falling into place.
And you begin to have an
explanation for the beginning
of life that sort of makes
sense in physical, biological,
and chemical terms.
MALE SPEAKER: So
once you have that--
BEN MILLER: You've
got these three areas
all coming together.
And now everyone's going,
shit, there's life everywhere.
Because we think volcanic
Earth-like planets
would be common.
We know that life on Earth
started, pretty much,
out of the box.
The early Earth, as you know,
was pummeled with asteroids.
We're now pretty sure
that life started even
during that period.
So that means that it couldn't
really have been in a pond.
A pond doesn't make sense
if the Earth's getting
pummeled with asteroids.
But a hydrothermal vent
on the ocean floor,
that makes complete sense.
And we know that these
planets are common.
And we know that life
can exist in such
an extraordinary wide
variety of conditions.
In fact, we're
the extremophiles.
This is the thing that
we've basically figured out,
that microbial life didn't-- the
first microbial life basically
used metals as a food source.
Now all life, the
life that produces
the food, the sugars
that we like to eat,
rips electrons off water,
stuffs them onto carbon dioxide
to make long-chain molecules.
Well, the first life
ripped electrons just
from metals that were
in the vent, again,
stuffed them onto carbon dioxide
to make long-chain molecules.
MALE SPEAKER: So once you have
that early microbial life--
which, let's assume that it's
quite abundant throughout
the universe--
BEN MILLER: Yeah, this
is the difficult bit.
Yeah, this is the
tricky bit, isn't it?
MALE SPEAKER: How do
you get to complex life?
BEN MILLER: So yeah,
microbial life-- common.
Most reasonable people,
I think-- certainly,
once you've read--
MALE SPEAKER: I'm
pretty convinced, yeah.
BEN MILLER: --this book--
you would believe, as I say,
it works straight
out of the box.
The trick is to get to
complex, multicellular life.
Now multicellularity,
cells just getting together
to make life easier for
themselves, that has, again,
emerged many, many times
throughout history of life
on Earth.
And you get multicellularity
within a billion,
a billion and a half years
of the first sign of life
on Earth.
Complex multicellularity,
where you get organisms
with tissues-- and animals
would be the best example
of that-- that has emerged,
maybe, a handful of times.
MALE SPEAKER: But
still more than once.
BEN MILLER: There's
three types of algae,
there's basically fungi,
and then there's us.
So out of five
times, only once has
any one of those branches
produced intelligent life.
And the problem with
all of those branches
is, if you follow
the family tree back,
you get to one, single event.
And this is the
really worrying thing.
You follow all complex
multicellular life back,
you get to one event, which
was the creation of one
eukaryotic cell.
So basically, in the
most brief terms,
there were two types
of single-celled life
on the Earth, the
bacteria and the archaea.
And then, again,
around something
like a billion and a
half years ago, there
was this one, single event
where a bacteria attempted--
or, an archaea attempted
to consume a bacteria.
And the two set up a kind
of hostage situation.
And the bacteria then
evolved into what
we call the mitochondria.
And that's where
we get the energy
supply to fund the huge
information overhead
of complex intelligent life.
The beautiful thread that
runs through all of this
is energy and information.
So we need that constant source
of energy in the vent to power
the creation of the
very first proto-life.
And then we need-- and the great
innovation of what biologists
call eukaryotes, creatures like
ourselves which are made up
of not these simple cells,
but these incredibly complex
eukaryotic cells, the great
innovation there is we have
basically enslaved
bacteria into our--
Within each of our cells, there
are these mini power plants
producing this enormous
amount of energy
so that we can store all that
information in a cell nucleus.
And we can suddenly
start to have
really, really complex life.
And as far as we know,
that only happened once.
MALE SPEAKER: And that's
the bottleneck, really.
BEN MILLER: That's a bottleneck
that we've got to get through.
MALE SPEAKER: Microbial
life-- quite common.
That's the bottleneck.
And then once you
get past that--
BEN MILLER: Shocking bottleneck.
Now there is one
element of hope,
which is, this did happen,
arguably, one other time, which
is in plants.
So what happened was the
archaea enslaved a bacterium,
created a eukaryotic
cell, and basically
created mitochondria, the
powerhouse of eukaryotic cells.
Then, another amazing
thing happened.
The other great innovation,
arguably, in evolution,
is photosynthesis.
Unlike in the vent, where
metals where the food,
it's taking light energy
and using that to power
the stripping of electrons
from water and pushing that.
So it's only light, which
is an incredibly good supply
of water, which is an
incredibly good supply, both
used to produce long-chain
carbon molecules.
That's a hugely
important innovation.
And that happened when a
eukaryotic cell enslaved
what's called a cyanobacteria.
Basically, it was
a type of bacterium
that had evolved chlorophyll.
And that's what created plants.
So there's a chink of
hope there in that that's
the same process, basically.
That's one cell
enslaving another cell
to do its dirty business.
So we enslaved the mitochondria.
We also enslaved the
plasma into our own plants.
So there's some hope.
You could maybe argue,
well, it happened twice
in the history of life on Earth.
But you can't get
away from the fact
that the plant thing
happened after the eukaryote,
so you've still got the
bottleneck back there.
You've still got the
eukaryotic bottleneck.
And that's the thing that
keeps me awake at night,
frankly, I think.
So I just think, this
isn't great, is it?
We've only got one example
of life to work on,
but there's still a
lot of information
there, in the history
of life on Earth.
But we're thinking--
it just ends up
with me thinking that,
intelligent life-- not common--
not nonexistent, but not common.
MALE SPEAKER: So if we assume
that intelligence life is out
there-- let's skip to the
other end of the book--
you talk about messaging--
BEN MILLER: Yeah, messaging.
MALE SPEAKER: --so, if we
were to receive a message,
what that might look like.
And you used the example
of hieroglyphs as something
that, we had a message, we
saw the information there,
but we couldn't
understand how to read it.
BEN MILLER: This is
a fantastic story.
This is a fabulous story,
particularly, I imagine,
if your brain enjoys
coding and decoding.
I mean, this is
just a great story.
So it's the closest thing--
I was trying to think,
what is the closest that
we've ever got, as a species,
to decoding the messages
of another species.
And the best example
I could think of
was, in the 19th century,
when they were attempting
to-- when Egypt was
suddenly opened up again,
to the Western world,
through Napoleon's attempt
to colonize it, and suddenly,
we had this flood of-- I mean,
there had been a few Egyptian
monuments, obviously, in Rome
that the Romans had collected
and brought back to Rome.
But really, they were mainly
what they call cartouches,
basically, the throne
names of the kings.
Those happened to be
the monuments they had.
They didn't have a
great deal of text.
And when Napoleon attempted
to colonize Egypt,
he took with him a shipload
of the French intelligentsia.
This is just such
a brilliant story.
They're called the savants.
And among them were Fourier,
the French mathematician,
there were some extraordinary
French biologists.
They collected--
MALE SPEAKER: Oh,
Fourier, as in tran--
BEN MILLER: Yeah,
as in transforms.
Yeah.
And they collected an
enormous amount of text.
Suddenly, they discovered,
wow, it's not just these throne
names on the monument.
There is a language here.
And they just couldn't crack it.
I mean, it took-- it's an
extraordinary story of how they
eventually managed to-- a
French character, Champollion,
finally managed to--
crack the hieroglyphs.
You know Young's slits?
You remember Young, the--
MALE SPEAKER: Thomas Young.
BEN MILLER: Thomas Young,
the British-- well,
among many things-- physicist,
he got part of the way there,
because he managed to guess-- he
had-- actually, ironically, it
was the throne names that
enabled them to crack the code.
MALE SPEAKER: Did they have the
Rosetta stone at that point?
BEN MILLER: Yeah, well,
the Rosetta stone--
it was the discovery
that-- yes, absolutely.
MALE SPEAKER: Maybe
explain what that
is in case people don't know.
BEN MILLER: So basically,
it's all over there
for the French in Egypt.
They're kind of
on their way out.
They're trying to
build a fort at what
used to be called
Rosetta on the Nile.
And one of the soldiers
discovers-- basically,
it's just a part of the wall.
It's just one of the bricks.
They're taking down
this ancient wall
to rebuild it-- is a stone.
And then, there are three
inscriptions on the stone.
One, they recognize
straight away
as the Egyptian hieroglyphs.
And there are two
other types of--
MALE SPEAKER: Greek and Coptic?
BEN MILLER: --Greek.
Yeah, there's Coptic, and then
there's another type of Greek.
I believe it was Demotic.
So they've got one kind of
Greek that they recognize,
another kind of Greek
that they don't recognize,
and the hieroglyphs.
And one of the savants
made the guess,
this could be the same bit of
text written in these three
languages.
MALE SPEAKER: And it's
really boring text, isn't it?
BEN MILLER: It's so dull.
Yeah, it's really dull.
It's basically a
kind of a eulogy.
It's saying how
they should honor
one of the kings of Egypt,
and it's really, really dull.
I mean, it's really, really,
extraordinarily detailed--
you know, this offering
must be made on this day.
And it's sort of like
bureaucracy, really,
in the extreme.
But this text was, of
course, what enabled
them to crack the hieroglyphs.
And that's exactly
what we don't have when
we receive our alien message.
We have no idea of knowing
what is in the message.
We can make guesses.
We can hope that the
mathematics is universal.
And they might send us prime
numbers to start off with.
And maybe they'll send us
a few fundamental constants
of nature, things that are
independent of whatever
measuring system
you use, things like
the ratio of the charge
on an election to--
MALE SPEAKER: Or Pi.
BEN MILLER: Or Pi.
We can hope that we know
what's in the messages.
But if we couldn't crank
the ancient-- you know,
if we find it so hard
to crack the messages
of the ancient Egyptians,
it's really hard
to see what hope there would be
apart from through information
theory.
So this is the wonderful thing,
coming back to the science.
This guy, Zipf, spotted--
this was news to me.
It might not be news
to many people here.
But this brilliant
discovery by this American,
George Kingsley
Zipf-- so he noticed
that if there's anything
that involves humans,
you can see a certain
kind of pattern.
So say, for example,
if you look at--
and things obey a sort
of logarithmic scale.
So say, for example, the
richest man in Britain
will be 10 times richer than
the 10th richest man, who
will be 100 times richer
than the 100th richest man.
And you see this pattern not
only throughout the whole
of human civilization, but you
also see it in human language
as well.
So if you take any text-- I
mean absolutely any text--
and you start plotting the
frequency of occurrence
of words against
their rank, you get
a straight logarithmic plot.
So in other words, there are
features of human interaction
and human language that are
independent of the messaging
system that you use.
MALE SPEAKER: It works
in all languages,
and it seems to be
inbuilt to nature.
BEN MILLER: Inbuilt to nature.
And they did it with dolphins.
And they also found that dolphin
whistles obey this Zipf plot--
not baby dolphins,
because they babble,
not adolescent dolphins,
because they just slag off
their parents the whole time.
But adult dolphins, you get this
beautiful, straight Zipf plot
if you plot their most
frequently used whistles
against the rank
of that frequency.
It's absolutely amazing.
And this comes back to
the work of Claude Shannon
and the fantastic work he
did in information theory
in showing that the
potential information
content of a message--
you can figure out
what the potential information
content is without knowing
what the message is.
And this is our best
hope, basically,
when we receive any messages.
So what does it mean?
It means when we're
messaging to aliens,
you guys are going to
be really important,
because we're going to have
to send the whole internet.
We'll send the
whole thing, photos
included, for several reasons.
I think it's important, in
this exercise, that we're
honest about who we
are, that we think
about our responsibilities
as a species,
that we take our global
organizations seriously,
that we consider
what we have to say
to other intelligent
alien species
out there, what
we have to offer,
what we're hoping to receive.
And we just send
them everything,
because the chances of them
being able to decode it
are minimal unless they have
a vast, vast amount of data,
and vice versa.
We don't want to just get
a picture of a stick man--
you know, the stuff that
we've been sending out.
MALE SPEAKER: On Voyager 1, it's
just a stick man and some DNA.
BEN MILLER: Yeah, on Voyager
1, a little stick man,
a naked woman, and a
walking stick or whatever.
We just send a lot.
We just send the
internet, the whole thing.
MALE SPEAKER: Let's see
if there's any questions.
So the book covers
quite a wide range.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So all the
things that keep you up
at night, [INAUDIBLE].
If humanity survives, we'll
eventually fill the galaxy.
Our descendants, or the
nearest equivalents,
will fill the galaxy
and the galaxies nearby.
And no alien species
has done that yet.
So we're not seeing them.
Something is between
them and doing that.
And either that something is
behind us or it is ahead of us.
If the problem is that
complex multicellular
life, eukaryotic
cells and stuff,
are very, very
rare in the galaxy,
that means it's behind us.
That means that we can
rest easy that we're
going to make to the
rest of the galaxy.
If it's ahead of us, we
should be very pessimistic.
And I worry about that.
So every time I hear
something that says,
this is why alien life is rare,
it's because of some filter
that we've gone through,
then I feel better.
BEN MILLER: Yeah, me too.
And of course, there's another
possibility, isn't there,
which is, it's there, but
it's simply not visible to us
because we just simply aren't
looking for the right thing.
And if we think how transient
our technologies are--
we send our first signals-- our
first narrowband signals were
radio waves that were just
blasted out everywhere
into space.
We then went almost
radio silent as we
started to-- our
own communications
became via satellites and cable.
We're now starting to use--
laser communication is probably
a much more energy
efficient and reliable
way to set up some kind
of interstellar network.
So that's probably the
way we're going next.
How long will that last?
Maybe that lasts 10, 20
years before we're modulating
neutron beams or something.
Who knows?
I take some comfort from that.
I think, well, we are
passing our-- so transient,
these technologies
and what we use.
Already, the
classical information
that we've got on
the internet, there's
going to be a new
phase where we surely
will move into some other kind
of more quantum-based-- we'll
move into some other kind of
way of moving of computing
if not of storing information.
So maybe they're there,
it's just like they've just
kicked over an ant hill.
And we mean nothing to them,
and they mean nothing to us.
Do you know what I mean?
MALE SPEAKER: In fact, you used
the example, at the beginning,
where if a species out that
discovers Voyager 1 floating
through the galaxy, if they're
superintelligent bacteria,
it's a snack.
But if they're
huge and ginormous,
they'll miss it,
because it's so small.
So we assume people
are like us-- people.
BEN MILLER: Yeah, we make--
and with some justification.
Because any life that's
on a terrestrial planet,
we can reasonably assume
that the same tropes
of intelligence,
sociability, languagee--
we can reasonably assume that
those will crop up again.
They won't necessarily
look anything like us.
Their biology might be
completely different.
They might be more closely
related to octopuses
than they are to shrews.
MALE SPEAKER: But they are
likely to have limbs, weapons,
eyes, features that we
see over and over again.
BEN MILLER: Exactly.
Yeah, and they'll have had
a similar journey to us.
But then, there's all
kinds of other things
that could possibly
be out there.
It's a fascinating
problem to grapple with,
because the only way you
can look for anything else
is by assuming it's like you.
Do you know what I mean?
But you're automatically,
then, just completely reducing
your opportunities
of finding anything.
So there's a real dilemma
right at the heart of it.
MALE SPEAKER: Questions.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Have you thought a little bit
about whether it's wise for us
to be sending out signals?
What do you think
the expected value
is that our first
encounter will be positive
for humanity as opposed
to possibly catastrophic?
MALE SPEAKER: Because Stephen
Hawking is very negative,
isn't he?
BEN MILLER: Yeah, I'm not
so-- don't get me wrong,
some days, I think, oh
god, what are we doing.
But then I think, well, we have
been broadcasting-- it's a bit
late now.
We've been broadcasting for
about 100 years, haven't we?
Was it the 1930s?
I suppose, a good 70, 80
years, we've been going.
So we're already 70 light-years
out in terms of stuff
that knows we're here.
So how is this going to pan out?
I certainly would expect that,
within 70 light-years of Earth,
there would be other
microbial life.
Do any of us necessarily
think that there
would be intelligent life?
That seems unlikely.
Intelligent life at some time
within the last 14.7 billion
years?
Interestingly, there's
a kind of cutoff.
As we look back in the galaxy,
we look further back in time,
it seems less likely that
life could have survived.
You go back more than about 5
billion years and galaxies are
so active, so
energetic-- there's
so much really hard
electromagnetic radiation
around-- it's hard to
see how life could exist.
So you're looking at
a window of about--
this is an interesting thing.
We're looking at a light
sphere of about 5 billion years
around us where there
could conceivably
be intelligent life.
And interestingly, our planet
is around about that age.
I find that interesting too.
There couldn't really
be life much older
than about 5 billion years.
Still, you've got
to figure, there
could be life out there with a
half-billion-year start on us
as of right now.
And of course,
communication, once you
start to get out further and
further into the universe,
it's that travel time.
So I just think it's
so far away that it
will be a great experience.
If we pick something up,
we'll know it's a signal.
We won't necessarily know,
for a long time, what's in it.
There's no way, unless
Stephen Hawking's right,
and they can wormhole here
and hoover up all our water
and then bugger
off somewhere else.
I mean, maybe.
Maybe.
But it seems to me
that they're not here
because it's a really,
really big place
and there's a
fundamental timing issue.
Civilizations,
maybe, don't last.
And certainly, technologies,
if not civilizations,
don't last long enough
for civilizations
to be visible to one another
at exactly the right moment.
Anyway.
MALE SPEAKER: Yes, sir.
Use the mic.
AUDIENCE: You talked a
lot about biological life.
And one of the
conclusions that I come to
is, if I wanted to travel
to another solar system,
for example, I wouldn't
send a biological being.
I would send an artificial
intelligence, or something,
robot, because all the
scales fit so much better.
And biology's quite messy.
And we're not really adapted
for the space travel.
Do you think if we
stopped talking about,
well, creatures with
arms and legs and eyes
and the idea of,
well, any sufficiently
advanced civilization out
there would have actually gone
through the biological phase
and their progeny would actually
be the machines they made-- they
may still exist in some form.
But do you think
we're actually looking
in the wrong places for
those kind of things as well?
I guess that's sort of
an open-ended question.
BEN MILLER: I completely
agree with you.
Yeah, I think that it would
be-- we wouldn't expect--
I mean, certainly, if alien
technology ever makes it here,
like you, I can't see how it
would possibly be biological.
And we can see, from the way
that we're-- we don't even send
people out into space anymore.
We send robots.
MALE SPEAKER: The head of
SETI thinks that-- because we
were watching that video.
I forgot his name.
BEN MILLER: Martin
Rees is very, very good
on this-- the Astronomer Royal,
Martin Reiss-- very, very
good on the robots thing.
That makes so much
sense, doesn't it?
Again, this is one of the
things about the book.
We're constantly
looking for ourselves.
There's some deep, primal
need, isn't there, out there
to find ourselves,
our own image.
But if we're really
seriously going
to look for alien
artifacts, then yeah,
I think we are genuinely
looking in the wrong place.
I saw a brilliant
article by Paul Davies
saying we should
check the Lagrange
points around the Earth.
We should have a look.
Is there anything there?
We're sending stuff out.
We're making use of
those Lagrange points,
aren't they, with some
of our future spaceships.
We should go and have a look.
Is there anything there?
MALE SPEAKER: Or the
center of the galaxy,
with a supermassive black hole
that's just emanating energy.
So that could be
a place as well.
BEN MILLER: Yeah.
There was a really great
Russian physicist as well,
Kardashev, who talks
about-- one of the things
that alien technology presumably
couldn't conceal would be heat.
Because no matter how
advanced your technology,
you've still got to
comply with the second law
of thermodynamics.
You still have to give off heat.
You still have to
degrade energy.
You still have to have an
energy source and degrade it.
So he had these scales
of civilizations.
He said a Type I
civilization was
one that harnessed the energy
of its home planet, a Type
II, its home star, a Type
III, its home galaxy.
And this is another
thing we should doing.
We should be looking.
We should be looking
for objects like that,
really large objects that are
dark apart from giving off
a lot of heat.
Those are other
surveys, sky surveys,
that we should be doing.
MALE SPEAKER: Is that where
a species surrounds a star?
BEN MILLER: Yeah.
Freeman Dyson-- it
was hand-in-hand
with the work of Freeman Dyson.
And Dyson came up this
idea of this thing
called the Dyson sphere, which
is basically exactly that.
You basically
surround-- the idea
is that the home civilization
uses up every ounce of sunlight
coming from its home star.
And eventually, the
star becomes dark,
because it's just completely
surrounded with technology.
So, hard to tell that
apart from a dead star,
which is also going to give off
a lot of heat and be very dark.
But what about galactic-sized
objects giving off--
objects the size of galaxies
giving off-- a lot of heat.
That would be a good
place to start looking.
MALE SPEAKER: We have time
for a couple more questions.
Yes.
Do you want to
just shout loudly?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
You mentioned Zipf's law and
what language looks like.
But as we get better
at communicating,
we get closer to
the Shannon limit
of actually making
it indistinguishable
from random noise.
Do you think that
means that we are
going to have to have other
civilizations deliberately
trying to communicate
with us to be
able to pick up the Zipf thing?
BEN MILLER: You're
exactly right.
This is the problem.
As our technology
gets more advanced,
it gets harder and harder to
tell a really good signal apart
from noise.
I suppose we've
got to hope-- yeah,
we just hope that they know
that and that they're there.
They're not-- they use some
rubbish coding or something,
just to give us a break.
But you're absolutely right.
Do you know what would do?
It would just be a
simple lighthouse beam,
or something like
that, would do.
Do you know I mean?
Just like an on and off, that's
probably the easiest thing.
That's what I hope.
I think, first,
you need-- what I
would do if I were sending out
a signal is just, first of all,
let's just have a beacon.
Let's just have it say,
there's something here,
so something that just may be
blips in prime numbers or just
uses some kind
of-- because you've
got to be able to tell it apart
from pulsars, which are simple
on and off.
So just a regular
lighthouse system won't do.
But let's do
something with number
and just send out some
kind of beacon signal.
And then, if
something contacts us,
then let's worry about opening
a communication channel.
I can't think that, really,
sending messages out is the-- I
just think if you just--
MALE SPEAKER:
Because wouldn't we
want-- we would just want to
know someone else is out there.
So if we found that,
that would be-- it
would answer our question.
BEN MILLER: That would
be great, wouldn't it?
That would be all
we'd need to know.
Also, it's extremely
energy efficient.
Yeah, come to think
of it, let's do that.
We cracked it.
MALE SPEAKER: The
gentleman in the far left.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thanks for the very
interesting talk.
I don't have a background
in this matter,
but I just looked up
[INAUDIBLE] outside light--
BEN MILLER: We have to sample.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] or
civilization will never
be able to [INAUDIBLE].
BEN MILLER: We'd have
to sample, surely,
hundreds of millions of
solar systems like our own
before we'd sampled
anything near enough
to hope to encounter a signal.
The great news is the whole
process is speeding up so much,
that will happen
in our lifetimes.
Everyone here, in this room,
will get to that point.
We will know, pretty
much, whether there's
intelligent life on the
next, say, 10 million,
100 million stars
within our lifetime,
thanks to Moore's law.
MALE SPEAKER: The head
of SETI thinks it's 2037,
thinks that we'll
have sampled enough.
BEN MILLER: We'll get there.
We will know.
We'll have a pretty good
answer to that question.
But you're absolutely
right, it's
impossible to draw any
conclusion, at the moment,
from that tiny, tiny,
tiny volume of spacetime
that we've sampled.
I completely agree.
MALE SPEAKER: Was it your book?
Or somewhere, I
was reading, SETI
would use the example
of-- the amount
that SETI, the Search for
Extraterrestrial Life,
have sampled is a glass of water
if the universe is the ocean.
BEN MILLER: Wow.
MALE SPEAKER: Of that sort
of order of magnitude.
BEN MILLER: Perfect.
We do know that we're
not in a-- we're
kind of in a conservation
area, at least.
It's not that busy.
We're not in the middle
of town, we know that.
But you've got to
figure, there's
a lot of-- yeah, in
100 billion stars where
there may be something like
11 billion Earth-like planets,
yeah.
MALE SPEAKER: Question here.
AUDIENCE: Quick question--
to maybe change the subject
slightly, I imaging
this kind of topic
must attract a lot of
interesting comments
and emails.
BEN MILLER: Yeah,
it's absolutely great.
AUDIENCE: Can you share, maybe,
a couple interesting ones?
MALE SPEAKER: Have you
had the UFO types coming?
BEN MILLER: Yeah, I
get the UFO-- sadly,
unfortunately,
it's of two types--
one, people who think
they've seen a UFO, secondly,
people who think they've
invented a time machine.
MALE SPEAKER: We
have one [INAUDIBLE].
BEN MILLER: I'll be
arriving in a minute.
Yeah, I don't know
what to do with that.
I mean, I just don't know
Because time machines,
doesn't that effect--
isn't cause and effect
quite important in life?
I have a problem with that.
And as to these
UFOs, I had a lot
of fun researching
UFOs in the book.
That's a whole other
story to get into,
but it's really great.
If I could just give you
one fact that I learned,
the guy who saw the first
flying saucer in 1947
didn't see a flying saucer.
He saw something that
was the shape of-- he
saw something that was like a--
he said it was like a pie tin
lid cut in half.
It was a sort of
semicircle that he
saw, a kind of crescent shape.
Right?
But it was misreported in the
press, described as a flying
saucer, and then,
afterwards, there
were many, many flying
saucers such as that.
A better example of the
psychology of priming,
I don't think you can find.
MALE SPEAKER: I love that--
BEN MILLER: But then,
there's no reason
that they shouldn't be here.
That's the point.
That's the point isn't it?
There's no reason
that they-- there's
an important question as well.
You can't dismiss that
on scientific grounds.
You can dismiss it
on nutter grounds,
but you can't dismiss it
on scientific grounds.
MALE SPEAKER: When people
used to report that they'd
been met by aliens,
the aliens always used
to be inside our solar system.
They used to be
Venusians or Martians.
And as our knowledge of the
solar system got greater,
these aliens happened to come
from further and further away.
So now, they come from other
galaxies and outside, away.
One final question
and we will wrap up.
Yes.
Oh, no.
Whoever Ben looks at.
AUDIENCE: I just [INAUDIBLE]
that 100 due to the fact
that we have been propagating
a signal for 100 years.
I think one of the
things about that
is that [INAUDIBLE] the total
amount of energy that we
transmit is relatively small.
There is tremendous
attenuation at that distance,
so it's like 1 by r squared.
At some point, the
strength of the signal
is actually lower than the
cosmic background radiation.
So I think that to be able
to produce a signal which
would be-- either you have
to have a directional signal,
in which case you, again,
have the same problem of which
direction you aim at or you
have to have a signal which
is so powerful
that you can still
see it at any appreciable
cosmic distances.
So given the power
source problem,
I think that one thing could be
that maybe people who signal,
like, other aliens who
signal, they can only--
you cannot muster a
power source big enough.
Like, we cannot
manipulate the Sun yet.
We could use that to
signal far enough.
So it could be that people
just signal, but only
to their neighborhood,
and that we don't see it.
BEN MILLER: Yes, that's
absolutely right.
That's absolutely right.
And I think one of the
hopes, really, of the next--
we don't know where to point our
telescopes to pick up a signal.
We don't know where to
point them to send one.
And of the things that--
you're absolutely right,
to get bang for your buck,
you've got to know where it is.
You've got to know where
you're sending the signal.
Otherwise, you're just going
to waste an enormous amount
of energy sending off
this billowing wave
of electromagnetic
radiation and just
hoping it's going somewhere.
And as you say, the
strength of that
is just dropping
off exponentially
away from the Earth.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
BEN MILLER: Yeah, not detectable
far enough away to be picked up
by intelligent life.
So one of exciting things--
MALE SPEAKER: Leave
us on a positive note.
BEN MILLER: I will leave
you on a positive note.
We have this great new
telescope, the James Webb.
It's an infrared telescope.
We know, from the
Kepler Space Telescope,
that Earth-like
planets are common.
So now, what we
do is we find-- we
need to find the
Earth-like planets
in the vicinity of the Earth.
And the first
thing we need to do
is image their atmospheres,
use spectroscopy to figure out,
are the gases in their
atmospheres in chemical
balance or not.
Because if there's
disequilibrium there,
we can be fairly
sure that there's
some kind of life form
powering that disequilibrium.
And then, we know where
to point our telescopes.
The chances of there being
intelligent life, as we all
know, thanks to the eukaryotic
bottleneck-- really,
really small.
But it will be a
sensible place to start.
And we can at least find life.
And I'm thinking--
I'm really hoping--
within the next decade,
we'll have the first results.
Nothing will be
conclusive, but we'll
have the first
results saying, look,
we looked at this
Earth-like planet
in this neighboring
solar system.
And look, there's oxygen
in its atmosphere.
And it's out of chemical
balance with the other gases.
So we know there's
something there.
Do you know what I mean?
AUDIENCE: Then we nuke them.
BEN MILLER: Yeah. [LAUGHING]
MALE SPEAKER: Please join
me in thanking Ben Miller.
[APPLAUSE]